we bring in head coach Bruce Arians
coach thanks for joining us what do you
make of what this article says that the
defensive formula was to pressure Newton
and don't worry about him as a runner
well we still worried about him but that
was that was the plan you know we tried
to take care of Christian McCaffrey and
cam those were the two guys that that
led the charge in a running game and
Todd had a great plan
his cam different than he was let's say
three or four years ago oh I think yeah
sure for sure I mean everybody's older
he's had some injuries but I mean I
still a dynamic player what did you
think they were gonna do on that fourth
down call something what they did you
know some some form of misdirection try
to get your eyes fooled and and get the
ball to McCaffrey yeah I didn't know if
you keep cam in and then I could still
get the ball to McCaffrey if I wanted to
like doesn't you sort of know who's
getting the ball now the question is
just tackling him if if cam is in there
then it adds a little bit more of an
element of we're not quite sure what
they're going to do that fair to say
yeah it's pretty fair to say you know it
was a fake Philly special they had shown
that that halfpipe pass before and you
know Vernon grant Vernon Hargreaves just
at a heck of a job to stay at home and
make a great great tackle the trying to
get your team ready for a Thursday night
how difficult is that yeah it's crazy no
practice you know you just have Walters
it's all mental repetitions and hats off
to our defense that's a complicated
offense to play on a short weekend Todd
Bowles just did a great job with a game
plan yeah that stood out the last you
know the first two games is your defense
you got to be proud of that and I agree
Todd Bowles I don't know what he's added
to it but you know there's something
different there yeah there's a lot of
energy there's a lot of positive
reinforcement every single day and Todd
says a great teacher and yeah it's been
a great improvement and we're trying to
build on it when's the first time you
were labeled a quarterback whisperer
at my old head coach in college coach
Jimmy sharp me kind of game up with that
know why I have no clue he just say hit
him one day and then and then we named
the book he said we gotta name the book
this but that puts a lot of pressure on
you Bruce like your quarterback is
always supposed to be good because
you're the combat whisperer well we've
been really lucky to a some really
really good players and God gets all the
credit for that I can't take anything
okay but what is the one thing that you
you want out of your quarterback or you
teach out of your quarterback no matter
if it's Peyton Manning or it's Jameis
Winston be careless be fearless and play
place play smart not scared and you know
yeah you have to be a leader and I think
all these guys you know Ben and Andrew
and Carson and Tim Couch and and no
Jameis now they had to grit you know to
be a leader what do you have to see out
of Jameis to know as you move forward
he's your franchise quarterback just
like he played last night you know in
the first game guys around him didn't
play as well this time we had a good
starter running game he did a heck of
good job of protecting the football and
making some place what did you miss most
when you're not coaching the
relationship the locker room you know
just being around the guys for really
the first time I felt old in my life
what was it like last night after that
win oh great feeling you know I don't
here's a better feeling to go on the
road and being a locker room after a
really hard fought win and just had
tears in my eyes just watching the guys
celebrate well you got emotional oh yeah
yeah for me you know it was him nobody
saw it
no no but do you go home and do you stay
up dude like you talk to your wife to
crack a beer what happens I crack a lot
of ground but we didn't get back till
about this we can get back to about 3:30
so it was it was to bed yeah I can't
imagine I think he would be so amped up
well maybe if it was a home game then
you're amped up and you oh yeah you're
staying up a little
you know what quarterback who's the
quarterback that taught you the most Oh
probably Don stock you know I back Don
stock up in college and he was he was
such a smart really good player and hmm
you know and as a young player I learned
a lot of things from him the
quarterbacks that I've had probably been
you know just let him play and not
overload him which that mean well you
don't want him thinking you know this
that and that don't over coach it and
for him it wasn't like we need to watch
a thousand just just learn our system
and go out and play because it's hard to
teach how been placed the position isn't
it it really is and I mean again God
given mother talent to break tackles and
improv it he's such a great player after
the play breaks down probably maybe the
best there is
i uncurious what you see when you look
at Brady that if you were to if somebody
never saw him you said I just saw the
greatest quarterback of all time if you
if you think that like how would you
describe what he does and why he does it
better than anybody who's played the
game way he's been in that same system
for so long and you cannot fool him he
seen everyplace ever ever drawn on paper
and and he he knows how to get the ball
out of his hand really really fast never
very sudden you see him never get sacked
or even hit but because he's getting
that ball out so fast
you've been very progressive with women
on your staff I'm curious what you
thought of Carli Lloyd kicking field
goals and the possibility of her trying
out for an NFL team she's got the legs
she's got to get it off a lot faster yes
but I wouldn't be surprised you know all
those girls have so much talent to get
the rhythm down in a three step kick I
don't think would really that'd be hard
for well everybody then said well is she
gonna tackle anybody I don't think
anybody said too about you know the
gramatica as well can they tackle
anybody like all of a sudden I don't
want my kicker to be a great tackler if
he does his job then he's not gonna
tackle anybody for sure I don't think
that's not a requisite for a kicker and
how concerned were you with the weather
last night was it scary at all at any
point yeah I never saw any lightning so
it's kind of like they kept saying that
little bitty cell was in the area and
then let's go play and then I hate those
weather delays but you know you have to
be safe well congrats coach great to
talk to you we appreciate your time and
good luck next week appreciate it thank
you yeah that's a bucks head coach Bruce
Arians Continental Tire Coaches Corner
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]